said that love has an expiry date how do
you guys feel oh on that oh I agree I'm
medium I think love is a Young Person's
game the average person only falls in
love like three times so you really
don't have that many shots at it
um
see the type of love that
wait how many loves are there can you
find it Pearl this Eros love there's
there's like three separate types of
love I don't know okay I think yeah
because I don't want to quote it wrong
um but I know there's there's different
types of love and I'm gonna toe the type
of love that we want but essentially any
girl that I want like that I want a
future with I want to marry I want to be
my girlfriend the type of love she has
to have for me the type of love to have
for my for my brothers and the reason I
say this is is
we can fight we can go but whatever but
at no point is are we ever gonna break
the relationship up
between my brothers and
some guys you you know you won't keep
all friends but for the day ones you're
always gonna fix it even when you're mad
even when this like even if when you
don't speak something is going to bring
the two of you to fix it because you
know that's that deep love when you let
it go too far you know when you get let
it go too far between and then you and
then you don't speak to someone and
maybe you Buck up to them one time then
you maybe try to yo let's go out again
bro you it's not the same love that's
what happens with relationships it just
takes one person not to give up as soon
as one person says I'm gonna give up
that's it it's all over so I just I need
that type of love that got all my
brothers and my family there's four
types of Love Arrow switches erotic
passionate love
um filler which is love of friends and
equals uh storage
um love of parents for children and
Agape the love of mankind okay so yeah
so the I was talking about this it was a
second one the love of friends is that
the one I was talking about love
um love of friends and equals it can be
the love between lovers when they've
been together for a long time and are
not so hot and bothered anymore it's
called brotherly love is the city of
Philadelphia the City of Brotherly Love
of course it could be sisterly love but
it is the accepting love of good
friendship that is the love that is your
for good health the love of the touch of
a loved one the fill a lot like lowers
blood pressure yeah you get the idea
that's the love and that's the love all
the mother loves not fake but all their
mother loves our based upon sign that
full of love is the one where's your
Bros and you're gonna yeah you know it's
not it's never gonna break and it's the
and upon and the love only gets stronger
it doesn't fade and that's the that's
the love that that relationship needle
that's the love that I would want
but in this day and age I I was saying
when we had our conversation I feel like
there's an expiry date on love because
it's like you love me until when I can I
can do something and then you'll just
give up on the love and then that's it
the Situation's done you're you're now
saying that you're gonna move on and
start chatting to other guys just
because a situation happened this is why
I don't know if I could get married
because it's like I could do something
maybe do something that you don't like
and then you're just gonna stop loving
me because of that situation so it's
that there's an expiry date or love you
love me until when are you pressed no
what about the unconditional love all
right
why do you say that are you pressed
because I was speaking about this I had
to let him understand that
to an extent I understand love has an
expiry date but it wouldn't have had
that expiry date if he but I wasn't
gonna hold me back if you were it wasn't
a minute
wait so if he what say that again it's
just a little bit of pettiness put it
this way I felt like the reason why
while I was looking at it like when we
were speaking about it I wouldn't have
had an expiration date for Kyle if I
felt chosen okay sorry Paul this is the
alpha Widow scenario I'm I'm picking up
on it like because the people because he
can't be your friend he can't be your
friend
no no because you're not over this like
it's like even what you've just said you
just like I didn't even realize we're
about to go back to you and him again no
he was having a healthy no but it is
healthy but there's something awesome if
he's pressed you just ask him he's
depressed no because I was wondering
okay well then yeah I'm I'm everything
you guys say no but no but see what
happened there this is why me as a man I
would not have him yeah as your friend
because already you're thinking back to
Memories now or things like you guys
this is too much this is too close and
I'm not insecure but I know a red flag
when I see it yeah and if I and if I I'm
just gonna be honest with you because
this is a this is education for you yeah
when you meet the guy that you like bro
you're gonna have to don't even wait for
it to do it you do a favor for her and
just step there I will do it yeah
because I've done it the last time but
then obviously like the brother was cool
he's from the ends and it was like there
was no situation in it he knew me from
that we have other friends outside of
that so we've seen it but men lie you
know men lie we like possibly possibly I
don't like that girl forget that girl
if he steps away that still doesn't deal
with the issue of what if the boy if the
boyfriend said to her I don't like I
feel comfortable with this friendship
and she wouldn't listen to what he's
saying you still got an issue and if a
girlfriend won't listen to one thing
there's probably going to be something
later down the line where he says babes
I'm not happy with this and she goes
well
no I don't care
and like and this is what I'm trying to
say to you before and because
when you first heard it it sounded like
controlling it sounded like oh you guys
are insecure but when you actually let
it play and you speak about it even you
you probably might you know some things
that get brought up you don't even
realize you get annoyed by some people
like oh you're capping that no that's
not what you know what I mean but you
shouldn't even care what he's capping
about you shouldn't care about no
pettiness you should just be like
but because you've got history and your
families are intertwined literally spoke
about it last week that's why I was like
are you like why are we talking about
this no but it's just a good topic
it related to the conversation hence why
I'm mentioned it but I wasn't relating
it to us yeah but bro she loved you and
you you you for every reason you was in
the right place you said it already you
was young but but obviously she was hurt
by it you're someone that she grew up
with families were intertwined he was in
a relationship and then you chose to
break up the relationship and Men
typically don't leave their women I've
never ever left a woman in my life any
woman I've been with has left me I'm not
saying I haven't tried to come back
afterwards but men we don't leave our
women like I said the other day if my if
I had a baby with my misses and she put
on weight I think I'll leave her I'll
try to make her go gym I'll try to and
if she didn't want to lose weight I just
got a fat wife that's it you know what
it is I'll be like you know remember the
pictures when you used to be fly I used
to be skinny but I'm not gonna leave her
no because she's ready she put start a
kid for me but but she you know I'm
trying to say to you like so ah man I
just think I think this is cheating
[Laughter]
I'm honest
what am I doing I just asked the
question but then can we throw it back
to see does love have an expiry I want
to hear everybody's opinion no no you
don't think so no my brother to you
think that love has an expiry date
no no
[Music]
no
if there's a lot of demand then there's
not true love but if it's true love it
never has an expiry date wait I think I
misunderstood your question so my
question is does love have an expiry so
I I meant like it does like over a
certain age I don't think it's love I
think it's respect but I don't think
like if you meet that person like I
think it loves a choice so I'd misunder
love is most definitely a choice I I can
agree with you yeah but I just feel like
because I've been in various
relationships it's like something can
happen and then the woman will just move
different and it's like you love me
until when I'm not saying I've stepped
out or done whatever but it's like
something could happen something even
minuscule and then it's like the woman
will just give up and then go on what
entertained by someone else so it's like
you love me until when well I think I
think men and women love differently and
I don't think I don't think women can
love men the way men love women because
that's why when uh when a man is
heartbroken it's a lot harder for him to
go through it then I feel like when a
woman is heartbroken I feel like men
deal with heartbreak a lot harder than
women do yeah but I think men can love
like multiple girls at the same time I I
don't know because I think if a girl's
Alpha widowed too hard like she thinks
about that guy like there are there are
um
I can't remember if it was like a
comment or where I read this but it was
like a lady in her 80s talking about a
dude she dated when she was in her 17.
like and they interview people on the
streets and they said tell me about your
first love and you just Alpha Widow
Alpha Widow Alpha Widow like I don't
know I think like women it's like
I don't I don't know which one's worse
because they both have it bad but I
don't think like I think men like have a
heartbreak with everyone with girls it's
like we either never want to talk to you
again and like you're dead like nothing
or like it's like the worst thing that's
ever happened and we'll talk about it
for years fair enough that's that's my
opinion
what do you think what is his question
you guys
um but the thing is you listed four
types of love right
so I don't know if some types of Love
have an expiry date like obviously
love between friends I don't think
really has an expiry date if the
Friendship still going
um that's a tough one I don't think I
could really answer that hey what they
what it love probably the sex one got
expired
that was probably going to explain that
steamy passion all of that business yeah
I think that that probably dies down at
some point like you know I mean just
chilling
you know what I mean
yeah
someone said
Jade is still in love with a Tupac and
dead man
as many of you know I was just banned
band talk and we I'm demonetized on a
daily
bam if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible